foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
Richmond football's back it's Sunday but
bro football is actually on right now
I'm on my laptop looking it up trying to
see what's going on bro
did we lose Greg or am I we lost Greg
but we're here all right we're here Sam
love it uh Ryan you were just uh I
shouted our show's producers who timed
up this show right with halftime but uh
but you were just talking about how you
had Justin Jefferson a square TD right
um how are you feeling about Kirk right
now uh well I don't feel great about
Kirk I feel like
a streamer anytime that I bet on the
Minnesota Vikings I always regret the
fact that Kirk Cousins is involved so
right now I think Justin Jefferson has
three or four catches and hasn't scored
a touchdown so that's where we're at
right now
scary I'm back guys oh
I'm back what up guys hey I don't know I
was trying to look up the game on my
laptop and then like logged me out but
it's all good I am back the Vikings are
taking on the New Orleans Saints uh time
uh no actually I think the Vikings just
went up going into halftime you guys
have any fantasy players on the team
because I do uh Justin Jefferson Chris
olave scored yes in any fantasy players
on that um during that game
Ryan was just uh melting down about his
Justin Jefferson anytime TD pick it's
not a good weekend for me it's not a
good weekend for me yeah a lot of
foreign
we're sending Good Vibes a lot of ball
game left a lot of ball game left
uh Sam Ryan it's Ryan bye bro bye we'll
we'll see you later let's get right to
the show guys let's get right to the
show uh my name is Greg that is producer
Ryan that you guys just saw we just
kicked off the show and that right there
to to the left of me right of me
wherever the way you're looking that is
a shark that is the man the myth the
legend Sam Richmond Sam we've been hot
bro
we've been hot like this show we have
been making if you guys have been
telling this show you guys have been
telling my man Sam Richmond you guys
even been telling me I gave a couple
pics man hey you guys been telling us
we've been hot on this show bro Sam just
talk about how hot we've been how how
you been feeling how's your bank account
feeling bro the family is hot it's and
it's great like you said everyone is
winning everyone's eating I think even
producer Ryan's eating even though uh
he's a Mets fan and is in dark spirit so
I just spent the hour rehearsal uh
roasting him but no man it's been great
uh I think I went five and one in the
show last week I say I think but I I
know that's the number I just have to
yeah you know you know you
um you went to Parlay we are we are on
absolute fire so hopefully we can keep
it going this week
Good Vibes are flowing The Good Vibes
are going to continue we are going to
speak that into existence all right Sam
we're here for a reason six Best Bets
we're giving you one minute on the clock
today
let's get right to it why not let's go
first bet first I'm glad that I get a
minute this week because I only had 30
seconds last week but Ravens plus three
and a half uh is my first pick look uh I
am a huge Lamar Jackson guy if you watch
our future show to start the year I gave
out Lamar MVP to at 20 to 1 I think he's
now like six to one and the Ravens are
in the Super Bowl I I just absolutely
love this team and I think it's been
proven out the start of the Season Lamar
is just on demon time he is in MVP mode
he's been the best player in NFL All
Season uh and I just think this is a
great spot for him I give me three and a
half points at home with Lamar Jackson
I'm taking every time I know the bills
are incredible they're coming off of
just an incredibly tough weather game
last week where like Stefan Diggs was
like this is the hardest game I ever did
play I had to put two IVs in or I got 12
seconds their secondaries beat up that's
really scary against Lamar and the
weather is really bad which Josh Allen
has kind of not been great in poor
weather conditions it favors the Ravens
with the points and the Run game Ravens
three and a half
there it is hey I like a Sam you sold me
brother I'm not gonna lie you definitely
sold me with that pick uh I like how you
talked about the rate the the weather
like how you talked about the weather
because that is a factor we know what
Josh Allen he isn't as effective
throwing the ball in the whole perfect
conditions give me a QB like Lamar that
can do it everywhere yeah exactly I like
it let's move on next pick bro
next pick all right I don't think people
are really gonna like this one but
Broncos plus three all right I'm gonna
go on a little tangent here and I think
you're gonna agree with me uh because it
affects the 49ers we are so biased
towards offense and how we've used the
view things right like if the 49ers
Broncos game last week was like Broncos
win 45-42 we'd be talking about how good
the Niners are how good the Broncos are
both these teams are through Super Bowl
threats but because their defense is
dominated we say like they suck and yes
the Broncos offense does suck 100 not
streaming that but they have an
unbelievable defense you saw it last
week you've really seen it every single
week the best unit on the field today in
Raiders Broncos will be the Broncos
defense and I know everyone is pretty
high on the Raiders despite them being
0-3 but like they're just not a very
good team their bottom 20 and offensive
and defensive dboa I don't think they
should be laying three points against
anyone uh give me the better defense I
hope Russ can be decent and uh and let's
cash
there it is Sam I love how you sat here
and preached defense I love that because
we all know offense sales the ticket the
tickets but defense wins championships
hey and that's very important we know
about that Raiders defense we know about
that Broncos defense Raiders and Broncos
they're nice we'll see talk to us about
your next pick Sam like these first two
picks bro loving The Vibes let's talk
about this third one
all right next one bears plus three
um not a sexy pick but this to me this
is more of a fade of the New York Giants
like this team is really bad like really
really bad and I know they have a good
record but again look at the metrics I
think they're 28th in offensive dvoa
like 25th on defense uh the Bears are
not very good on offense but the one
thing they can do is run the ball and I
know everyone's making a big deal no
Montgomery this week but Herbert is
really good
um and the and the Giants really
struggle to stop the run so the Bears
can kind of play ball control run the
ball on the Giants it's going to be a
really low total because both these
offenses kind of suck so if you're
giving me three points in a game where
that might be 17-14 you know 13 10 type
of game I'm taking the points I'm taking
the Bears to run the ball uh Daniel
Jones is not good that offense is not
good uh I I really like the plus three
with the Bears today
Sam look at you you stopped with four or
five seconds left because I was going
over on the first two so I was like I
really gotta go quick here one of these
days I'm gonna like perfectly balance it
right on the timer
you really like that play I I like it
too Sam I I this this New York Giants
team are they really for real that's the
question are they really for real we
don't know I think they should be laying
three points against anyone like against
anyone
I I think it's going to be a close game
I think that one's going to be a close
game like that one Sam your three picks
in you have three picks left but before
we get to your fourth pick you know we
gotta check in with producer Ryan
producer Ryan welcome back to the show
welcome back to the show
the audience
we want to know I want to know my man
Sam wants to know what are the audience
talking about are they feeling my man
Sam speaks or uh or is it a little bit
of bad vibes going on in the comments I
don't think Sam wants to know I don't
think Sam wants to know every week I get
roasts in the comments and every week we
cash tickets so it's like last week that
guy roasted me and then I went five and
one so what do you want me to do yeah
that's true stop coming at me audience
I have beef with you Sam there was
absolutely no reason to bring the Mets
into this because now I got to deal with
four four Arnold in here saying let's go
Braves in the chat this is this is an
NFL Sunday
Arnold gets a hoodie send that man a
hoodie I I'm gonna have nothing to do
with that that's a you deal with that in
your DMs uh but rsj says that man uh Sam
was goaded last week uh God's other son
which is just a phenomenal name uh says
Ravens win the Super Bowl uh so he's all
over the Ravens uh people are on the
Raiders uh in this chat they love the
Raiders uh Benjamin Webb says Raiders
taking that one My Guy cross Crosby is
going to eat so
I don't know oh good good luck scoring
against the Broncos defense
um
I mean he's he is referring to the
Raiders defense there though so no I
know but I I'm not disputing that the
that the Broncos are not going to score
a lot of points but I don't think the
Raiders are going to score a lot of
points okay Sam that's a good thing you
know if the Public's on one side you
know what we like to do we like to go on
the other side so all you Raider fans
please please go move the line why not
go I don't like the idea that Ryan
thinks I don't know who Max Crosby is
all right listen again we got beef right
now so I just I'm just like you know I
know on that note by producer Ryan let's
get back to the show because we got to
get back to the matter at hand Sam you
are the legend you are the goat you have
are the one that's true I am the golden
God get out of your commenters get out
of here producer Ryan I am the man come
on
hey Sam come on give him the fourth pick
though you are the man though
for fourth pick again people aren't
gonna like this we gotta get rest in the
comments I like Seattle today plus three
and a half
um look I know we all like the Lions we
like Dan Campbell he eats people's
kneecaps off he drinks 60 ounces of
coffee a day love the guy this is still
Hawaiians though like this is still a
below average team and that's a lot of
points to be laying
um I know the Seahawks aren't very good
but their offense is sneaky like Geno
Smith is leading a pretty decent offense
they struggled against the Niners a few
weeks ago offensively but like who isn't
going to struggle against the Niners
offensively that Niners defense is
incredible we'll talk about that later
but their defense stinks for sure like
Seattle Stevens is not good but the
lions are missing a lot of dudes no
Swift yeah no saint Brown no shark like
they are missing some guys they are
probably not going to be able to take
advantage of that Seahawks poverty
defense and the Lions defense sucks so I
like Geno to kind of run it up a little
bit give me three and a half points give
me the hook
um I I really just really like the spot
for Seattle
there it is Sam hey Scoops scoop Sam
Scoops is what we like here on on the
six pack we love we like scoops and Sam
just gave the scoop you guys don't know
a lot of the alliance offensive players
are out today they're out and I'm
talking about key players on that
offense key players on that offense Sam
gave us a scoop Seattle plus three and a
half
I like it Sam I like it that's four down
we got two more to go talk to me talk to
the people what's next
all right so let's see again probably
getting roasted I know this is not uh I
think the public is on the other side
here but I really like the Bucks today
we have a really rare opportunity today
an opportunity that almost never comes
about uh I honestly can't even think the
last time this happened but you have a
buy low spot on Thomas Brady like when
was last time that happened like five
years ago and the Pats got blown out
against the Chiefs on Monday Night
Football this never happens
um again speaking to what we talked
about earlier like defensive offensive
biases the Bucks have the best defense
in the league
um that matters like that's a huge deal
and I know everyone is like making a big
deal about the the Bucks offense for
sure it's been bad but like let's look
at the context here Brady has been
throwing to JV receivers this entire
season you get Evans back Julio and
Godwin are questionable if you get one
of those guys back Brady has a good set
of weapons they're not going to be elite
they're not going to be the Chiefs
offense but they can be good enough and
when you have the best defense best
defense in the league you have a really
good chance to win this game at home so
I'm going over the timer but I I really
like the Bucks today I think this is a
really good example
you went over your time I know you heard
the buzzer bro you went over your time
but hey I love I love the sales pitch
but bro hold on I'm just I got
I gotta scratch it you're taking Tom
Brady over Patrick Mahomes and the
Chiefs today
I I just think I think it's a really
good spot for them
um and you know the Bucks they've kind
of had Holmes's number if you remember a
little super a few years ago I lost a
lot of money that's not a point though
Sam that's my point like it's October
2nd it we aren't in January when Tom you
know be Tom we're in it's October 2nd
and you're rocking with the Tampa Bay
over the cheese I don't know let me
bring in producer Ryan I will just say
this before Ryan comes in here with his
propaganda every time Brady has been
doubted for the last 75 years that he's
been playing football he comes back the
next week the next season whatever and
dominates and show everyone that he is
still here and I think that happens
today
that is true I love that Sam but let me
bring in producer Ryan producer Ryan we
have to talk about this
my man Sam's rocking you're the voice of
the commenters and the commenters hate
me and you hate me right now so you know
I just I gotta have a Target to go after
that's fair I will say that me and you
are both splitting the hate right now
we're both getting me and you are both
getting slandered in here so it's fine
uh we have uh perhaps who says Tampa
wins uh Tiger King says agree Bucks beat
the Chiefs uh Chicago says goat against
wannabe goat so the goat wins
we're calling Patrick Mahomes a wannabe
goat I don't think that's not accurate
I'll be honest wannabe goat is not
accurate they had they bro they had
statistics of like Patrick Mahomes stats
compared to people that are already in
the Hall of Fame like at that point of
their career bro Pat is literally
drowning some of the people I will say
this though I will say this though this
is not anything against Pat Mahomes I
agree with you Greg I think he's
absolutely but
the chief's offense has been good this
year but they do not they haven't looked
like the chiefs of old offense last year
I think they actually do miss Tyreke a
little bit even more than I expected
Mahomes just doesn't have those Dynamic
enough weapons and I'm sure as the
season goes along and those guys get
more comfortable that offense is going
to be top two top three like it is every
year but they're like top 10 right now
it hasn't been like a runaway Elite unit
um and I think he he misses some of that
explosiveness on the outside
uh definitely when you lose somebody
like Tyreek Hill you're gonna miss that
but hey this is Pat Mahomes we're
talking about producer Ryan we'll see
you in a couple seconds brother uh Sam
it's time to get back to the
nitty-gritty because we got five we
locked in that five bets I like them
let's talk about your six bet
talk to me nice talk to the people let's
go Sam you're gonna love this one Greg
49ers money line I I think most people
were surprised that like the Niners were
favorite I'm surprised they're not
bigger favorites to be honest like
Shannon absolutely owns Sean McVay and I
I don't want to bring up the bad
memories of tart dropping the
interception last year but and producer
Ryan could uh could pull out the stats
but uh Shannon is absolutely owned
McVeigh this Niners team has owned
McVeigh uh they've been able to run the
ball like crazy I think this is a really
good bounce back spot for the Niners
they the their defensive unit will be
the best unit on the field again we need
to stop like we need to stop with our
offensive defensive biases the Niners
defense is really good it will be the
best unit on the field if the Niners can
run the ball which they have against the
Rams pretty much every time they've
played they'll do clock control this
this feels like a week where you see the
Niners in in the form they looked at the
end of last season where they're just
going to run the ball they're gonna have
nine minute drives they're gonna control
the clock their defense is going to get
some stops they'll probably pick off
staff for twice I I really like the
Niners here
Sam it all sounds really really good man
it sounds good and I am a Niner fan as
everybody know but one thing's first
searching
that man named Jimmy Garoppolo is the
San Francisco 49ers quarterback and as
long as he is the quarterback
we will need a lot of prayers in San
Francisco uh Ryan Ryan talk to me talk
to the people how are the audience
feeling about this San Francisco money
line play me being a a fan I don't even
know how I feel about it I hope they win
I want them to win but Jimmy has the
quarterback I don't know is the comments
talking about Jimmy at all or are they
talking about this the San Francisco
winning or losing well to touch on Sam's
Point real quick uh Kyle Shanahan is
seven and three lifetime against Sean
McVay straight up so uh he does appear
to own him in the words of Aaron Rodgers
uh Vincent Jasmine says right before you
drop that San Francisco pick says Sam's
sitting at four and one in my eyes uh
beaklev says San Francisco money line uh
honcho Mack says Sam's going oh and six
how do you feel about that I just got a
notification on my phone that Justin
Jefferson is in the red zone right now
Ryan so uh you might want to keep an eye
okay I mean if he scores I'm you I'm
gonna freak out so uh Irvin says Lions
all day so he's fading your Seattle plus
three and a half it's mixed that's fine
usually I feel like people are slightly
learning it's usually all negative we
have a mix of positive they see that
you're winning and we have the suckers
and losers who just need to see it again
well it is going to be fun like one of
these weeks I obviously will go like two
and four and one and five and just when
I come back the next week it is just
going to be an avalanche of how stupid I
am and how of an idiot I am but you know
what commenters I still love you I
appreciate you for watching the show
um
DM some of us and we'll give you hoodies
because we appreciate your support and
that is how you do customer service
that was customer service with a dash of
sales that was very impressive
um yeah I don't I don't know I feel like
people also don't realize how hot you
are right now but that's a you know
that's a separate story but uh all right
Sam do you wanna you wanna jump into
some anytime TD picks here
let's do it am I going first
Ryan pull up the full screen graphic
anytime touchdown props let's see it
there it is
take it away right
so for any type touchdown
so hold up we'll give uh we'll give our
guys right you have the wrong thing
pulled up bro we need the touchdown
right what are you cooking there on the
right that looks like an interesting
parlay I said every time you guys go
away from me I'm I'm trying to I'm
trying to add a little a little bit of a
Sprinkle to my parlay but uh all right
here we go now let's do this thing all
right most bet anytime touchdown props
at the DraftKings Sportsbook uh you see
Jonathan Taylor there leading the way up
minus 165. all last season this guy was
like minus 200 or longer odd or shorter
odds sorry uh you're getting at a minus
165 and the public is hammering it you
got Nick chub there in the middle uh
minus 125 going up against the Atlanta
Falcons and their swiss cheese defense
and then Justin Jefferson like I have
been pleading like I have been begging
since this show has started I have bet
at plus money and I need him to score
that game is going on right now I think
the Vikings are still winning but these
are your eight most bet anytime
touchdown props at DraftKings Sportsbook
guys people in the comments we need your
locks we're boosting a pick here so we
need your locks jump in the comments
jump in the chat and give us your luck
for today
Greg you want to take it away there it
is there it is Ryan I need that Justin
Jefferson play myself he's on my fantasy
team I just talked about it but Sam I'm
getting right to it bro Naji Harris
everybody in fantasy's been asking where
is Naji what what's going on with Naji
what's I think that Steelers offense I'm
not saying that they figure it out
figure it out today but I think they
take a step in the right direction and a
step in the right direction is leaning
on my man Nazi Harris and then getting
them into the end zone so I'm rocking
with Naji Harris to get into the end
zone Sam which way are you uh right
today
well I the Vikings are settled for
another field goal because Kirk Cousins
can't score a touchdown from first and
goal from the four so I'm sorry for you
guys
um I'm going Lamar I think it's plus 140
so we'll get on the plus money side but
like I said earlier I'm I'm all in on
Lamar this year I think this is a sneaky
like MVP preview game
um and I think Lamar is gonna absolutely
ball out uh he's been running a little
bit more I think he's got two rushing
touchdowns on the seasons already so you
give me around plus 140 plus 150. I'm
all over it uh just love Lamar love that
guy Sam's rocking with Lamar I got my
man Naji uh Ryan
come on back man come on back and talk
to us about the comments let us know
what the comments are talking about and
then like give us a pic from the
audience why not
yeah guys so we got bad news uh the
audience is letting me know that Justin
Jefferson just dropped the touchdown uh
oh no
to find that out then people just
flooding the chat with Justin Jefferson
just shot the touchdown all right I'm a
Broken Man uh but anyway the chat seems
to love uh Nick Chubb we got rap rap
saying uh Kyle Pitts Nick Chubb DK
Metcalf we've got Fabian Cantu saying
Nick Cub I'm assuming he missed the h
I I'm gonna say Nick Chubb yeah uh Seth
Ro saying chubba wubba uh we've got
let's see Michael bowling saying the
Vikings are a tire fire yep totally
agree there uh Brandon Bostrom saying uh
Stefan Diggs for sure getting a
touchdown Jalen hurts definitely a good
bet too uh Fabian Cantu has now added
the H and then put it in all caps Nick
chub uh it I don't know about you guys
but the I can't see more Nick Chubb than
right now I mean Nick show blocks I kind
of want Nick Cub though can we yeah
Kings will boost that yeah if we can get
Nick Hub I would I'm with you on that
okay hey uh Nick Cub Nick Chubb whoever
it is I I say let's ride why not I got
him on my fantasy team as well so I like
the pick Nick Chubb we're locking it in
we're gonna boost that we're gonna boost
that here from minus 125. guess we're
taking that up to plus one ten and if
you you want if you guys want to bet all
three picks mine Sams and yours
DraftKings is boosting it 25 they're
boosting It Up by 25 uh with the big
with the BR betting anytime touchdown
pay their parlay check out social Pages
for a link to the Boost all right guys
it's my favorite part of the show guys
last week we hit the parlay
this week we are back we are absolutely
back to hit the parlay Again Sam
honestly we might be on to something we
honestly might be onto something
producer Ryan he's here
we've been talking we've been talking
we've been up since like early this
morning 6 a.m my time up early grinding
talking about this parlay Ryan pull up
the four that you have the four legs
that you already have
for the parlay there it is you guys see
it the wait Ryan we're going to start at
the top brother sir the Buffalo Bills
plus nine and a half against those Raven
Sam me and you both can win here we both
can win we're locking that one in the
Jacksonville Jaguars plus 20 and a half
against those Philadelphia Eagles hey
that defense
that all they got to do is just come out
and play just don't get blown out just
don't get blown out
Tennessee Titans plus 17 against those
Colts like that one and Sarah we we both
can win here again you can win on the
money line with the bucks but I just
want to win with the plus 13 and a half
on the Chiefs those are the four first
legs right
are you ready to get to get to the
nitty-gritty like are you ready to to
finish off this parlay oh I was born
ready dude I was born all right let's go
let's go let's wait Greg can I answer a
quick question
because I'm sure there's people in the
comments like oh minus 700 minus 600.
just a question did a meteor crash into
Earth last week yes or no
a meteor did not crash into Earth left
and that's because the parlay hit so
before you commenters get off I didn't
see any meteor crashing Greg hit he's
gonna hit again Good Vibes continue hey
Good Vibes a money hey Sam someone what
my my OG partner once told me money is
money so if we're finding a way to win
money
can't be mad at it in my opinion but all
right Ryan I need you to take me to the
Green Bay Packers New England Patriots
game please
take me to the game uh Tom not Tom Brady
for the the Patriots but Aaron Rodgers
is going for the for the for the Packers
we don't know who's playing quarterback
for the Patriots today we don't know
maybe it's Mac Jones maybe he's back
from his injury maybe not but one thing
I do know is the Packers plus one
sitting at minus 498 is going to it so
we are going to add that to the parlay
Ryan let's get back to it uh take me to
that I will say I think Mac Jones Mac
Jones has been ruled out it's going to
be Brian Hoyer who I think is 1 and 11
in his last 12 Stars producer Ryan could
look that up but one in 11. so Packers
plus one uh is pretty safe to be honest
you telling me that makes me want to
take the Packers minus something to make
this parlay even more juicy but we're
going to leave it we're we're going to
leave it because this it's it's gonna
hit good vibe is in the atmosphere thank
you Ryan Cardinals Panthers Ryan you
know what to do alternate scroll all the
way down and I mean to the very bottom
and we're talking about the Cardinals
here plus 13 and a half Baker Mayfield
is the quarterback in Carolina
I do not like that take I'm taking the
points with the Cardinals last but not
least last but not least Ryan
take me to the Monday night game because
after we hit these six we're gonna sit
on it we're gonna let it marinate some
people might cash out some people might
not cash out you know what I'm saying
but we're going to marinate we're going
to sit on it and wait till tomorrow's
game
where my 49ers is taking on those Los
Angeles Rams
and I know Ryan you know what to do just
scroll all the way to diners funny line
uh no no no no no
scroll all the way down and everybody
might be thinking I'm siding with those
San Francisco 49ers
Jimmy Garoppolo is the quarterback no
Greg you're betraying the Niners
I'm not saying that you're gonna lose
Sam we can still both win here we can
I'm not saying that they're going to
lose all I'm just saying is the better
bet
in this situation is the Rams Plus 14. I
think that this one I think I've ever
seen you bet against the Bay Area team
in my life I I don't know what to do
with my hands now I'm Chuck
hey you know sometimes you gotta you
gotta do what you gotta do in order to
see the money and that's exactly what
we're trying to do we are trying to see
the money Ryan we got seven plays
there they are you can let's let's go
from the top
seven plays on Ryan's screen there it is
the Buffalo Bills plus nine and a half
Jacksonville Jaguars plus 20 and a half
the Tennessee Titans Plus 17. Kansas
City Chiefs plus 13 and a half the Green
Bay Packers plus one the Arizona
Cardinals plus 13 and a half and the Los
Angeles Rams plus 14 and a half and I
want you guys to remember this a win is
a win
and that's all we're trying to do here
we're just trying to win so there is the
parlay Ryan how you feeling about the
parlay bro you are we getting Good Vibes
yeah this is I love this parlay it
wouldn't be a week though if I didn't
advocate for Cowboys money line in this
so I it is disappointing every week when
I come in here and it's not there but
this is not missing like we got hot last
week and it's just gonna carry on and
continue and we may never lose again
that's how I feel
hey I like that I like the sound of that
uh let's carry on to the next segment of
the show over or under Sam we're we're
gonna vote me and Sam we're gonna vote
whether players go over or under their
props each person only needs
Sam if like just just explain a little
bit a little bit rapid fire you know
what I mean yeah rapid fire we're gonna
go through this fast uh
let's get to it
these are the most popular player props
on DraftKings right now
other than uh let's get to it Tom Brady
Tom Brady over or under one and a half
passing touchdowns today
against the Chiefs
on three Sam three two one
buy or buy and low on the goat we're
buying low talking about it a little bit
just touch it a little bit all right he
didn't sell his weapons back he's
getting some of his weapons back again I
think this is Buy Low on Brady I think
he's gonna have a big week
Sam says Buy Low on Brady Patrick
Mahomes over or under one and a half
passing touchdowns Sam this is my
fantasy quarterback so you know which
way I'm going but let's go three two one
I'm going under I'm sure this is like
big plus money but the Bucks have the
best defense so I'll take my chance at
him a home's under why not
Sam's taking his chances all right Sam's
taking his chance can't be mad at it
Aaron Rodgers over under one and a half
passing touchdowns today uh I think this
one's gonna be easy Sam's like oh yeah
this was easy talk to him a little bit
Sam just a little bit uh the the Pats
are a mess I think the only concern is
that they're the Packers might get up so
big that they just like run the ball and
and milk the clock but uh I I think he
might catch this in the first half
Sam says he might catch it in the first
half all right all right and now for the
matchup everybody is talking about the
big quarterback matchup Lamar Jackson
Josh Allen we're starting off with Lamar
over under one and a half passing
touchdowns over with Lamar always over
demon time MVP mode bet that man bet on
him I'm gonna go over with Lamar I think
he's gonna have a good game Josh Allen
over under one and a half touchdown
passes this is the most non-anytime
touchdown prop bet today
Josh Allen over one and a half touchdown
passes three two one I'm going over he's
having a year this year
yeah I'm going over too Raven secondary
has been iffy I think that's gonna be a
high scoring game
high scoring game bring back producer
Ryan because Ryan we want to know what
the fans are talking about in the
comments and we're going to grade some
of their bets because they they've been
in the comments talking about us they've
been in the comments talking about my
man Sam's bet they be in the comments on
BR betting saying fade Greg fade Greg
but I want to know I want to know what
what are some of their best so me and
Sam can get our link back right now I
will say this chat has never heard of it
under before because you guys have been
doing this and it's just over over over
uh also Fabian Cantu wants to know what
Kansas City Plus was in the in the
parlay since I'm a man of the people KC
plus 13 and a half uh if you missed that
but uh their bets Rhino Jr Texans money
line saying forget forget the five and a
half we don't need it give me the money
line against the Chargers how do you
guys feel about that
uh uh it's like a B minus yeah yeah I
was higher than I thought yeah the
Chargers are a mess like they've
suffered so many injuries this year
um I don't know if the Texans can score
enough to actually win the game but I
think they'll keep it close to their
defense but uh but I don't hate it
yeah I don't hate I don't hate the risk
reward on that that's what I don't hate
the risk reward that's why I get to beat
Fabian Cantu Browns minus one
um I'm on the I'm on the other side here
so I have to give it a d sorry so
Greg
all right Greg make uh why do you like
the Browns today
the way they looked last week was pretty
impressive and I think that this week
they come back the Falcons the Falcons
the Browns are more to me they got a
running game you know they got Amari
Cooper on the outside in the Falcons
there's just a lot of moving variables
but they are at home but I'm taking the
grounds taking the Browns too many
moving variables out there
fair enough I like the Falcons today but
I want to I want to get to a lot of
people's picks so I won't go on a big
rant okay uh Kevin Morgan
Stefan Diggs anytime touchdown
yeah you got it I mean
he's been on fire Gabe Davis is back
this week so maybe less targets for digs
um that's a little of a concern but the
Raven secondary as much as I love the
Ravens is pretty meh right now so uh I
like it do I see a plus plus plus Greg a
plus plus plus I like Stefan dates to
get in the end zone with Josh Allen has
his quarterback
I'm better than that it doesn't get much
better than that uh Mike Ritter in here
we'll go in with this rookie wide
receiver class has been loaded he's
going with one of them he's going with a
New York Jet Garrett Wilson anytime
touchdown
he's back he's back what what are the
what are the odds on that uh plus 2 30.
it's pretty good I don't I don't hit the
Jets today
um I couldn't get there
um as you and I talked about like Joe
Flacco might actually be better than
Zach Wilson yeah but but uh I like that
odds there so good job Ritter I hope you
cash it
yeah I like that one too he got hurt
last week and I wanted him on my fantasy
team really really bad but if he's back
in the end zone that's a good good look
for the rookie uh in New York but guys
my man producer Ryan is here let's just
sign off when I'm right here hey it's
been fun it's been fun we've been
winning a lot let's continue winning
we're sending Good Vibes into the
atmosphere my name is Greg Ivory for Sam
Richmond and producer Ryan weed
are out of here let's go catch some bets
y'all
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]